hello I'm gonna stop guy remember it so
you don't have to and welcome to another
installment of what's that real not
utilizing an incredibly popular icon
it's like not utilizing an incredibly
convenient cameo hey you get a water
around here oh you want some lawyer yet
MC Hammer is one of those people known
as the music you play at a wedding when
you want to show how ironically white
you are MC Hammer used to be everywhere
he had the number one rap album concerts
show appearances commercials he was all
over the place now that's the way the
Hammer run for the border and at the
height of his popularity came what many
consider to be the most embarrassing
part of his entire career and that's
saying a lot the MC Hammer cartoon
Hammer man yep this really happened in
1991 we got a Saturday morning cartoons
so ridiculously bad that well we're
talking about here given that ice some
critic he didn't even put a Saturday
morning cartoon on TV no he put his on
the big screen to embarrass himself it
ran for only 13 episodes and you can
quickly see why the cheapness value of
this show is award-winning ly lazy in
that I just made up an award to grant it
so I could give it that title just look
at how half-assed this is did they skip
the animation process and just color the
storyboards look at this they didn't
even finish this half of him in the
opening kids would see that every week
you couldn't just move him a little to
the right that was too much effort for
you but don't take my word for it
probably the biggest testament to this
show self-aware humiliation is that they
spend as much time as possible not
showing you the cartoon take the intro
for example most of it focuses on hammer
himself rather than showing much
animation and tell me if this doesn't
feel like the longest most drawn-out rap
ever here's how its dominate all along
go The Legend of the hammer and how I
began to grow he was given magical shoes
by the pop mow down dude together they
had power they still opposed what was
right but Ben was getting old and he
couldn't keep up the fight right so vets
and his granddaughter they went out of
the world so just by the man they knew
good jab who was worthy of the load they
met a guy named Bailey we dancing every
night he played every day his heart was
out of sight so open up the bag
Jesus how much do you like store you
gonna go into he went to the store to
get himself some milk but he saw it
expired so he looked for the receipt but
he couldn't find it so he just called it
quit but then he looked down and saw it
was on his beat so he went back to the
store after almost a minute and a half
of that intro we'd then cut to the real
hammer dancing with some kids then after
that we cut to hammer again literally
telling you what you're about to see no
he gives the whole episode away Joey
goes all around old town putting
graffiti everywhere on everybody's
property and she gets to trouble the
graffiti comes alive sometimes he even
reveals the lesson before you're
supposed to learn it right like graffiti
most people put it where they're not
supposed to know I can't be good but
it's not right when you put it on other
people's property and that's what the
show is all about today why the fuck
would you save the message first if
you're gonna spend the majority of the
show hammering it away we're kicking it
off today after we cut two even more
kids dancing we finally start the
cartoon that's gonna teach you the
lesson hammer just taught you what's
that gonna go but don't worry if somehow
you miss the lesson in the beginning and
throughout the rest of the episode
hammer pops up again to tell you once
more what it is tagging somebody else's
property with graffiti is illegal and
it's wrong
I don't think gas stations filled as
much so next time you feel like doing a
little artwork do it on some paper and
who knows you might end up drawing on
the car tilling like hammering man one
day no
around that should be the punishment for
kids doing graffiti the story if you
missed that lawyer rings length opening
is about a youth leader named Stanley
Burrell which is hammers real name who
comes across an old man named Gramps and
his granddaughter Judy Gramps has a pair
of magic talking shoes I'm just gonna
assume they sound annoying that's all we
need they used to transform Gramps into
a superhero named soul man but he's
retired and looking for a replacement
and of course Stanley literally fills
his shoes and becomes the superhero
hammer man whatever secret powers well
aside from making the choppy animation
look more shitty than cd-i game it's
actually kind of hard to tell we know he
can make objects dance to his music and
parish you with his pants but aside from
that it seems to be relying on the vague
properties of animated music notes he
also seems to have backup singers which
first sounds kind of cool like you know
a few sidekicks to help him kick some
ass or something but nope they literally
just sing backup they don't contribute
at all you know when he's not hammer man
they just randomly sing about shit yeah
what are their lives like do they just
sit around in alleyways and eat out of
garbage waiting for something to give
them material to sing about but a hero
is only as pathetic as as villains and
these are some pretty lousy ones indeed
the lineup includes the face Lamarr
Meister who brings graffiti monsters to
life rap Polian who wants to shrink the
world so that he's taller than everyone
else
and Paula Onion she steals shoes monster
as you'd imagine their character
development was on par with anything
Batman the Animated Series was putting
out you're just doing this because you
had an unhappy childhood you want to
talk about yeah and that's all you need
two-face has got nothing on that
backstory they always partake in two
pastimes one scheming of plans that make
no sense like drawing for a fee and
bringing it to life to rob banks when
you could just draw money and bring that
to life I'm kidnapping Jody yeah she's
the pawn sacrifice most kids shows used
to have
down you're asking for half the time
hammer man doesn't even need to save her
the bad animation does it for him
looky here oh she's tied up who'll save
me uh but literally the next scene she's
just free and she runs away what the
hell happened there were the villains
just like is that too tight let me untie
that for you you want a pillow I can get
you a pillow think you want me to just
turn myself in I would love to turn
myself in for you no okay if you could
just fill out this survey please give me
ten out 10 that'd be great and hey if
you turn that in the next time you get
kidnapped you get a free cookie she
wouldn't be too bad if she was a better
character but this is one dumb kid she
never puts together that both Stanley
and hammer man are the same person
oh is that humanly possible even Clark
Kent took his glasses off he doesn't
even have the energy to do that okay
even if puppy pants somehow managed to
disguise a person's identity she knows
about the magic shoes now knows life's
been real hard spending all that time
traveling around with me looking for the
right person to wear shoes yeah remember
in the intro they clearly explained that
she's helping grams to find a
replacement for a superhero and suddenly
a superhero wearing those shoes who
looks like your friends family pops no
seriously what the fuck is wrong with
you it's his seizure dancing really too
distracting to put two and two together
but I know what you're thinking does any
of that really matter when we get to
listen to some of the incredible rap
that hammer is capable of me the hip hop
stroke Clara yes that's a hard yes half
the time the sound design is so bad you
can't even hear the rap
[Music]
and like I said even when you can you're
mostly wishing you couldn't I've had it
with these crooks they give me
indigestion to head it back to jail
about that there's no question this is
not an effect I'm a rapper not a hair
donor what does it even mean maybe
that's why they spell out the sound
effects all the time they're afraid you
too many people won't do their job and
just forget to put the actual sound
effect it no are they figure that the
show was just so damn crazy that nobody
would even care then they were right
from terrible writing to some of the
most low-budget animation available for
God's sakes I can't say throw him hammer
man is an anomaly you have to see to
believe you'd swear this was like a
parody on MADtv or SNL but no it's the
TV equivalent of babies kids the game
there's apparently no plans to put the
show on DVD but truth be told that's
kind of - our loss something so lazy to
the point of Surrealism should be
remembered it should be documented just
for the curiosity of how fascinatingly
desperate we can get to put a name on
anything Hammerman is just as bad as it
sounds but truth be told it kind of
makes it more fun to watch if you're in
the mood for one of the most
embarrassing excuses to make a show ever
this is definitely one worth the search
so look online find those VHS a--'s and
check it out for yourself
[Music]
and of course it's proved that just
because you can do something with a
popular name doesn't always mean you
necessarily should do you want to do a
let's play crossover a Bart's nightmare
only if I get to wear my Melvin costume
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys dog walker here two things to
address first off you might be wondering
is that the review for this week uh no
it actually is not we needed one more
week on this review because it's a
review we've kind of want to do for a
while and we we're trying to put as much
effort into it as we can so we really
wanna get as close to write as possible
so yeah we're taking one more week on
this review but it'll definitely show in
the final product so look forward to
that and then of course second we are
doing the charity shout out and the
charity this week is charity water and
this is a charity that does exactly that
it gets clean fresh water to people
particularly in third-world countries
that don't have access to it and that's
crazy everyone should have access to
free clean water that is vital as what
you need to survive and it's basically
like being punished because of where you
were born not having something bad
essential and this charity goes and they
get clean water to these people they're
starting a new campaign this month
trying to help raise awareness and you
can help as well it's just something
where you can do anything you want you
can bike you can draw you can do a
triathlon you can do pretty much
anything to help raise awareness and
raise money and show support for this
wonderful cause and it's something
that's going on right now and you can go
to their website and check it out and
you can see what you can do it's a
wonderful chance to do just all sorts of
various options to raise awareness of
this and the money all goes to getting
water to people that really really need
it that just need good clean water to
survive to live and to be healthy it's
the most vital thing you need it's what
we all need and this is a charity that's
trying to get it to everybody so please
if you have a chance definitely go check
out this website and see if you can show
them your so